this Valentine's Day you may not be with  someone you love in fact you may be with  someone you barely know it all so give  them the gift that says you care at  least for the next 24 to 72 hours the  kay Jewelers tinder collection the  perfect statement pieces for when the  statement is you do you ferment for when  you want to say be mine when you're  looking for a way to say thank God you  look like your profile picture whether  you're confirming identity making plans  setting ground rules or even calling it  quits give them something to remember  you by  that isn't a virus kay Jewelers tinder  collection for the type of love that  will last a night time  [Applause]